welcome to CBS this morning we're going
to begin with breaking news it comes
from New Zealand where officials say
they believe there are no more survivors
after the sudden eruption of a volcano
overnight at least five people have died
there and death toll is expected to
climb because 20 others have been hurt
some of them very seriously an unknown
number are still missing the volcano on
white island a popular tourist
destination lies 30 miles off the coast
of New Zealand's mainland officials say
interrupted while dozens of people were
on or around the volcano including
passengers from a cruise ship Lisette
Raymer with our partners at New
Zealand's news hub is at nearby FACA
Thani heads where officials have set up
an emergency service center right now an
active search-and-rescue operation is
underway to find these missing tourists
police say they are unable to make
contact with anyone on the island and
the smoke ash and dangerous conditions
are hampering the desperate rescue
operation fear and panic spread quickly
as white island volcano erupted Monday
near a boat full of tourists
launching plumes of ash smoke and debris
high into the air
another group of tourists were seen on
the shore near by watching the eruption
in horror a lot of smoke coming from a
webcam apparently captured a group of
tourists inside the volcano's crater
moments before the eruption police say a
number of the visitors came from a Royal
Caribbean cruise ship that was in port
rescuers were able to evacuate more than
20 people from the island more than a
dozen people were hurt
most of them suffered from burns our
thoughts are absolutely with the friends
and family of those that are injured and
those that have died officials could not
confirm the nationalities of the
deceased and say the risk of another
eruption is making it difficult for
rescuers to return to white island it is
important that we consider the health
and safety of those that are going to
rescue those on the island what white
island does is clear its throat
scientists say they noticed an uptick
and volcanic activity at the site in the
last few weeks including tremors and
toxic gas emissions the last major
eruption of white island was in the year
2000 on the scheme of things for
volcanic eruptions it's not large but if
you are close to that it is it's not
good authorities may later investigate
why tourists were still allowed to visit
the island when scientists had recorded
an increased volcanic activity out there
but for now the priority as the New
Zealand Prime Minister juice in Dehradun
says is to get any of the stranded
tourists off the island and onto the
mainland for CBS this morning Lisa
Kramer fuckathon e New Zealand